hi there steve kaufman here
today i want to talk about corrections
correcting people
when they make mistakes in
the process of learning a language
um last few videos i've talked about how
language learning is a
subconscious process how we learn
subconsciously gradually improve without
realizing it that a lot of our
deliberate efforts at learning are
somewhat futile
i did a blog post over at my blog and
i'll leave a link up here
where i quoted some
studies that showed that
uh
what they call form-based instruction or
in other words teaching grammar and
corrections
have relatively little
impact on
the learning process
and i believe this to be the case
and it's funny because that's one of the
comments that seems to
uh elicit the most sort of critical
response from
you the listeners so i wanted to delve a
little further
into this whole issue of corrections and
why i think they are quite unimportant
um
i've been learning romanian
um
and i've been at it for five weeks now
and uh i'm doing quite well i mean it's
i've never learned a language so quickly
partly because it's a romance language
mostly because it's a romance language
uh partly because of how i'm using link
i think i'm using it more and more
efficiently
partly because of the resources that i
found on the internet
having people initially
translate and record a lot of basic
sentences for me which i imported into
link which i listened to i still
listened to
radio romania and the resources there
and and so forth
now um
i'm now speaking to three tutors i talk
three times a week
and i talk
and as i mentioned earlier one of the
tutors
for a while insisted on correcting me
and i finally had to insist with him
that i don't want him to do that because
it basically
saps my enthusiasm for our conversation
i think we're having an interesting
conversation on some subject and he just
wants to correct me
so
we stop doing that we just talk now and
i get my report afterwards with
some of my mistakes which i import and
it
either has some impact or it has
no impact it has some impact it's
content it's it's
part of the whole language environment
but the main reason why i think that
language correction is not a good idea
is because fundamentally i believe
language learning
is something that you have to do
yourself you have to take you the
learner have to take responsibility for
your own
learning
it is true that a lot of people claim
that they like to be corrected
and of course they're trained to like to
be corrected because that's how school
works you write a test you get seven
right and three wrong you get seventy
percent
uh we're all used to that we kind of
think that if we don't have someone
looking over us correcting us
constantly giving us feedback that we
aren't learning but my view to that is
that it's time to grow up and take
responsibility for your own learning
i know as a learner
which things i have trouble with
in romanian they have three versions of
the future
uh they have some structures where you
use the infinitive
and somewhere you use like the
subjunctive to express the future for
example you can say
uh
voy uh avia i will have which is the
infinitive
voy uh voiputia voy uh
where you are now using the subjunctive
and it's so difficult to get that i have
looked at the rules many many times but
the point is that i know it's a weakness
uh as there are many others in romanian
things that are difficult
and so i every so often i refer back to
the grammar
and but when i read and listen i try to
focus on those things
so that i notice them more and then when
i speak i get them wrong
and then i look at the rule again and
then i listen again and i read again and
i pay attention but it's my
responsibility i know that it's a
weakness i don't really need anyone to
correct me because i know more or less
when i get it wrong in a way when i get
it right
i think where correction comes in
is when we are quite advanced in the
language where we have certain
things that we are saying that we don't
realize that we're saying wrong
and so correction
can be useful when the person is already
quite fluent and has certain ingrained
patterns that may come from their native
language which they don't realize that
they're getting wrong all the time but
for a long time in the language we know
very well that we have trouble with
tenses we know that we have trouble with
pronouns we have trouble with cases in
russian we know where our problems are
and so we don't need to be corrected all
the time if we are speaking
then we should be enjoying the process
of speaking
um
and get some rhythm and curse elicit a
response from the native speaker and and
hopefully we pay attention to what the
native speaker says
and pick up on how they say things
correctly because if we're talking about
a particular subject it's very likely
that some of the same vocabulary and
some of the same grammatical structures
will come back to us in what the native
speaker says but we don't i don't think
it's
constructive or productive to correct
the learner and i think particularly the
learner shouldn't be expecting the
correction all the time the learner
should take the initiative to go there
and dig
dig
into the content when they're listening
and reading
dig into whatever grammar resources
they're using whether online or in
little book
be aware of where their problems are and
then go back and dig and that constant
that sort of
virtuous circle
of
noticing things not being clear not
understanding getting it wrong
going back to the grammar resource
looking at it still not quite
understanding or understanding but still
getting wrong and gradually over time we
get better but it's our responsibility
it's not
i don't think that effective and the
research shows
that a major emphasis on grammar
correction and grammar instruction
doesn't work and of course we've seen it
in our schools where that's the major
emphasis so
i think that for an independent learner
that
correction or relying on correction is a
bad habit
and i have not been corrected very much
in my romanian i've been at it for five
weeks
when i look up an article now on uh
radio romania
because they have a number of news
articles that are printed like
literally there is hardly a word that i
don't know there like i can read all
those articles when i listen i
understand a lot of it now i was
recently sent an audio book
and the pdf of a novel
now there there's a lot of words that i
don't know so that's a whole new area
now but because i've been focused on
news and
economics and stuff that like that you
know i'm i'm doing fine there and i
can't use all those words myself but
with time i will be able to and i've
achieved that in five weeks if i had
gone to a traditional program with a
traditional instructor instructor taking
us through the different parts of speech
and the different structures in the
language and correcting us and giving a
test i mean i don't think that in six
months
i would be as far along as i am
now after five weeks
uh and so you may say yes you're
experienced and you're better at
languages than some people and which may
be true but more than anything i'm
experienced at language learning and i
know
that this massive input
constantly getting more of the language
in you
struggling to learn the words
starting now to use it without worrying
too much
about
grammar
certainly this is nothing one of my pet
peeves is the people who ask questions
why is it this why is it that can you
also say it this way can you how about
this other way and then they'll come up
with some totally strange way of using
this language and saying is this correct
i i just don't understand people who do
that
go to the source
go to the
listening and reading that you're doing
let it come in
when you have questions
have by all means have a grammar
resource handy that you go to a grammar
is not a curriculum
grammar is a reference source it's
something you go to from time to time
and often but it's not something that
you learn
one step at a time at least not in my
experience and of course when i speak
about language learning i talk about my
own experience and other people may do
it differently but i at least
want to make it very clear as to why i
feel this way about correction how that
it's not very useful and for learners to
be expecting or relying on correction i
think is an impediment to language
learning there you have it
look forward to your comments bye for
now